[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson site there he is he's still
talking it's been going on a long time
this week's impeachment trial in the
Senate has done what you would have
thought would be impossible in the era
of Donald Trump it has made politics
boring again the trial isn't just dull
it's dull in a highly aggressive almost
coercive way watching it is like being
trapped by your drunk brother-in-law at
Thanksgiving as he explains in forensic
detail how he's managing his 401k after
went six minutes you start fantasizing
about jumping out the window that's the
experience of it unfortunate there are
no windows in the Senate chamber so
we've had to watch the entire thing and
after four days of this we have reached
a conclusion this isn't really about a
phone call that Donald Trump once made
to Ukraine it's not even about Adam
Schiff now obvious dream of winning a
Daytime Emmy talented thespian though he
is it's actually underneath it all a
policy disagreement permanent Washington
was enraged that Trump violated neocon
orthodoxy by criticizing middle-eastern
Wars and by promising to deescalate
tensions with Russia nothing he has done
before or since has made them angrier
than that did it was a direct threat to
their ideas and to their paycheck so
they decided to make sure he could never
make good on those promises and Adam
Schiff conceded as much in his closing
comments today
Trump's real sin Schiff explained was
questioning military aid to Ukraine why
because it is America's duty to remain
on the brink of war with Russia forever
and indefinitely the United States has
roughly 68,000 troops stationed in
Europe they serve alongside troops from
28 other countries that comprise the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization or
NATO they are holding the line against
further Russian aggression and the press
as you may have noticed isn't in the
habit of asking Adam Schiff to explain
himself and that's a shame in this case
because it would be nice to hear him
explain what the hell he's talking about
in fact the European Union has almost
four times as many people as Russia does
its economy is more than ten times as
large
oops haven't made it to Western Europe
in 75 years and they won't be coming
anytime soon they can't and by the way
if the Europeans were worried about a
Russian invasion they built an army to
protect themselves they haven't done
that because they're not worried and yet
according to Adam Schiff America must
must keep 70 thousand troops in Europe
away from their families to guard
against the ever-present threat of
Russian invasion for real he said that
his fellow Democrats nodded in vacant ID
agreement if it weren't for American
military aid to Ukraine Schiff went on
Putin's armies might have conquered that
country going on to seize Poland and
overrun the continent you'd have to
learn Russian to spend junior year in
Florence watch now Ukraine is not a
member of NATO but Russia's invasion of
Ukraine it was a threat to the peace and
security of Europe if we had not
supported Ukraine in 2014 if members of
this body had not voted overwhelmingly
on a bipartisan basis for military
assistance to rebuild Ukraine's military
there is no question it would have
invited further Russian adventurism in
Ukraine and perhaps elsewhere in the
heart of Europe it would have weakened
our allies and exposed US troops
stationed in Europe to greater danger
and believe it or not
Schiff went on like this all day long
voice rising eyes bulging and over time
he began to sound less like a
congressman from Burbank and like a
character from a Tom Clancy novel the
greatest threat to America Schiff said
isn't Russia's first guards tank army
it's the president of United States who
quite possibly could be the first
non-voting member of the Politburo
in other words gentlemen the penetration
has been complete if a president can be
so easily manipulated to disbelieve his
own intelligence agencies to accept the
propaganda of the Kremlin that is a
threat to our national security now by
now you may be wondering how exactly is
this the impeachment we were promised
was this supposed to be about the abuse
of power and the contempt of Congress
aren't those the charges how do we get
to the part where Russia invades Belgium
well actually it's been a long time
the genesis of Donald Trump's
impeachment trial it turns out wasn't
the now-famous Ukrainian phone call or
even his victory three years ago it
actually began on February 13th 2016 on
that day that's the day that Trump
debated Jeb Bush Ted Cruz in the rest of
the GOP primary field in South Carolina
at Columbia I think Trump said things
that until then no major Republican
candidate had been willing to say out
loud he called the Iraq war for example
quote a big fat mistake he said America
ought to reach an agreement with Russia
rather than fighting proxy wars against
them he called the trillions of dollars
we spent in the Middle East a waste at
the time it seemed like Trump was
attacking Republican orthodoxy but now
it's clear and this impeachment makes it
crystal clear what was really going on
Trump was attacking the consensus of
both parties in Washington and that's a
neoconservative consensus both parties
work together to keep America
overextended abroad stuck in Quagmire's
across the world that enriched defense
contractors and lobbyists while killing
our finest young men and hollowing out
this country Donald Trump promised a
different path as a candidate he said
was time for American troops and
American dollars to protect American
interests not the interests of some
backward Arab Petro state or corrupt
Eastern European oligarchies against
United Opposition in Washington you'll
remember Trump got the nomination and
then won but Washington still has not
recovered from the shock and rather to
learn from the results they've doubled
down they blame the defeat on Russian
Facebook ads that nobody saw and in
response to those ads that nobody saw
they're demanding that America risk war
with the world's largest nuclear power
now we've mocked Adam Schiff many times
in this show we hope to in the future
but on this matter were deadly serious
if this guy's public statements reflect
what he actually believes he is
dangerous to the country for real